welcome to the pink marketing show the
number one podcast for growing and
scaling your business with online video
I'm Heather Torres and I'm Sean Connell
and we're from think media and if this
is your first time listening welcome
this show is dedicated to helping you
learn how to get your content notice and
the latest money-making strategies
working right now online so whether you
want to grow your YouTube channel or
maximize online video across social
media this is for you well today we have
a special treat for you we have Omar l2
Corey from the think media team here
super pumped excited to be here and Omar
has really gotten us into video
podcasting and a few months ago at
groweth video live our annual conference
that we host here in las vegas you
shared a really awesome keynote tell us
about it
yeah so essentially what I shared was
just a case study of one of my clients
and how their their video podcast has
been able to help grow their online
sales from 30k to over 250,000 dollars a
month in just eight months and so that's
just 30 grand month over month simply
implementing video podcasts to the
business and so I think this is
encouraging because a lot of the things
that I'm sharing could you could apply
in your business in your YouTube channel
in your podcast even if you're thinking
about if you doubled with the idea of
starting your own podcast and
essentially how to even get started
there's a lot of information there but
yeah I'm super excited for everybody to
check this one out yeah so here's your
all-access VIP front row seats to the
recording from Omar's keynote at girl
with video live today I want to talk to
you about how why you need to start a
video podcast and we're going to talk
about a business I took in just a few
short months growing 30k a month in
online sales month-over-month and then
also growing their YouTube channel to 14
thousand subscribers in just nine months
so let's get started
today's objective or this sessions
objective is I just want to give you
reasons using this case study you know
Shawn said this earlier that reasons
come before results and I think before
you see results the thing that I
actually keep you going
is your reasons and so I want to also
give you tips on how to start your video
podcast
and the purpose of this is that I would
leave you convinced it's a start-up a
podcast so you can make more money
nobody in this room wants to make moans
good so you can make more money and
build your brand Authority digital audio
accounts with the biggest share of time
spent on mobile with social media and
digital video following Shawn share that
and then so that that goes to say that
video podcast is the ultimate strategy
because you when done right it fills all
the things above it fills the audio /
aspect of things it fills the social
media aspect of things and then it fills
the the online video aspect of things
you know it's funny cuz we say LinkedIn
bio but we like forgot that it stands
for Lincoln biography just okay looking
about my name is Omar Khouri I uh in
2007 I chose broadcast journalism as my
elective in high school dang he's young
or you guys are like dang he's not old
but I really enjoyed it I really enjoyed
shooting videos I enjoy doing podcast on
pocket like PSAs and like fun
announcements for our high school and I
bought a bought my own camera and
pirated Sony Vegas because I was only in
high school I know how to buy stuff and
and then I just got to go I just started
editing videos and creating content I
started vlogging in 2007 didn't make
money and by 2008 and so I quit I have a
family that's facts this is a picture of
my fam yeah family go families this is
Amanda and little Ruby Grace a little
bit more I have an agency that does
content creation for businesses and
offers YouTube strategy to help grow
businesses audiences and I also work at
think media's lead content creator and
then I also have a YouTube channel where
I teach a beginner photography and
videography I don't put too much effort
in it but just a power tip that I've
applied VRA I've applied VRA to my
channel and with just like 12 videos I
have 16,000 subscribers I'm not trying
to plug anything other than strategy
works guys this this VRA thing is really
legit and so if you even haven't taken
VRA really reconsider because posting
all these videos on
YouTube or posting wherever you want to
post it and without having strategy it's
gonna be very frustrating alright so
meet Mike and Shawna Jones look a
good-looking they are all that house the
spray tan no I'm just kidding
we met back-end we met back in 2015 I
was working at a church as a creative
director but also helping with small
groups as being small group coaches and
so I was assigned to coach their small
group they had a group that met in their
house and they just talked about life
week every week and then I remember
their during that time Shawna was doing
lash extensions out of her house and
this I mean I also knew them enough that
they were they were grinding I knew that
wasn't it wasn't an easy life that they
were living but nonetheless they decided
to give a night of their week to
encourage people in our church and have
them over have some pizza
and so this is just like a picture of
their house room set up where Shawna
doing lashes and Mike's doing mortgages
at the time so this is like 2014-2015
and she would hustle she would spend
hours you know during the night on
Instagram following girls in the
industry and what that means is simply
girls that work at the pools here and
the club's
girls that like if you can get fresh
lashes on them they'll probably tell
their friends and then they'll probably
hit up Shawna just a little [ __ ] that
costed nothing but just hours of her
time at night bed a hard time paying the
field bills they had they have a funny
story where they were you know they're
paying rent and they couldn't make rent
one month so they sold the refrigerator
to make rent and it's just crazy things
like that to think that you know they
have just an early store and they they
they just grind it man they just they
saw that they there was some promise
there they felt like there was something
there
and so with hard work and they really
just went all-in on their business in
2015 they opened up their first salon
here in Vegas and just fast-forwarding
two and a half years they now have three
salons here in Las Vegas that oh that's
pretty gnarly
they have so three salons in Las Vegas
across the valley 100 lash artists are
working under them they also have a
training course that certifies lash
artists so they're they're bringing
people into the industry to through
their brand and so essentially these are
all things they had in place prior to
you know going in with video podcasting
or even YouTube and so I just want to I
I just wanted to paint this picture of
maybe you there's an aspect to your
business that you're missing that could
probably help your video podcast really
pour and fire into your flame or is it
gasoline into the fire yes I like that
all right so here's some things that
every business needs in order I think to
stay relevant and stay effective they
are practitioners the first thing is
practitioners you can also put this like
services so they are boots on ground
they this allows anybody to stay
relevant and also be on top of trends so
I'm a content creator myself but if I
just if I stop taking photos and I stop
doing video just because I grow out of
it
then I'll start speaking into an
industry and I'll just be the old guy
that's using old terminology and still
talking about DSLR cameras when
mirrorless cameras are the thing to do
and so you know this the practitioner
aspect of their business helps them stay
relevant secondly products do you have
something to sell raise your hand if you
have something to sell awesome that's
like half of the room so you got 50% of
this room needs to work on visible
product or a digital product and don't
be I think I don't think have to
overthink it either I think a little
just a quick power tip you can you can
record yourself do one thing and sell it
as like a pay-per-view in its entirety
so whatever that is if that's you know
your a consultation for someone getting
their eyes checked the full process
somebody recorded you it's 15 bucks on
your website just a thought
the third thing is they're professors as
a stretch I just wanted to do three P's
because I you want to keep it consistent
but essentially they have an educational
wing to their business do you have an
education educational wing to your
business three things that you can have
on your business that can just create an
ecosystem because people can meet you at
the
education that could stay in your world
because you're offering them supplies
and then you're still doing services so
you're staying up on trends so as they
keep learning from you you're staying up
on trends a man so so just Mike hits me
up this is like a year ago he's like hey
Lamar
how does your YouTube channel have so
many subscribers but you upload zero
videos and I told them I was like it's
the power of making searchable content
for an audience that I have
predetermined which was beginner
photographers and videographers and he's
like could you do that for us I was like
nah man this is this is too valuable cuz
if you hire me and we apply these things
you can cut me off at any time and this
will keep working for you forever and
ever
he's like let's go grab lunch and he
asked me again and I was like all right
man let's do it and so always ask what
asked twice you never know so we started
a video podcast and and we picked the
day to shoot all the podcasts this is
what we can call batching right so this
is what they had January first before we
started doing their YouTube channel
video podcasts they had 30 subscribers
because they uploaded iPhone videos and
all their last heart is subscribed
they're in the room and that's why
they're laughing so hard okay uh they
had zero podcast dreams because they
weren't doing it and they were doing 30k
a month and online sales probably for
the last six months of the last six
months of 2018 so that's a screenshot of
their December sales just 29 grand how
we did it we bought the gear that's the
first step you gotta buy the gear in
order to do it but don't overthink it we
also we just simply shot this in one
angle straight on angle and I shot it in
4k
most of our phones in this room actually
shoot 4k and then I edited a 1080p
project I know that probably flew over
some people's heads essentially I filmed
it really high resolution and then I
edited a smaller resolution so I can
have multi look like we have multiple
angles and I'll show you an example in
just a second then we captured the audio
on a zoom recorder edited each episode
straight through this
the headache I wasn't we're not trying
to cut videos or cut content so it came
over quickly it was just like all right
ready all right here we go
start the show hit record and then end
the show hit record and then the Edit
was just that simple in celebration of
the launch of this brand-new podcast
we're giving away two tickets to our
annual conference grow as video live a
$1,500 value all you have to do to enter
is make sure you subscribe leave us a
review on Apple podcast and then take a
screenshot of your review and go to
think marketing show calm for the rest
of the details content without strategy
is just stuff so you want to make sure
you got strategy you put out all this
stuff III say this if you have the best
product and nobody knows about it
guess what Fran you don't have the best
product someone can have 50% a good a
product that you offer maybe and because
more people know about it I'm sorry they
have the better product that's just the
reality so who wants to know what they
got now because everybody likes the
transformation so right now they have
fourteen thousand two hundred
subscribers yeah let's give it up that's
that's fourteen thousand people that
understand what they're following that's
fourteen thousand potential lash artists
people who are in the beauty industry
that want to start their own businesses
it's pretty strong audience to have they
have fifty six thousand podcast streams
from zero that's incredible
and as of August they've done 220 sales
and just online sales
that's 30k month-over-month turn up just
breaking that down just a little bit
deeper fourteen thousand two hundred
subscribers what does that mean that
means and I would say imagine this for
your own business I know we're I'm
sharing this example well how cool would
it be if you had four hundred thousand
minutes spent on your brand two point
five million minutes matter minutes
watched there in your world you have 2.5
million minutes spent in your brand
world your business whatever that is
that's pretty powerful and just just a
power tip the Google Adsense already
they've they're gonna make 20 100 bucks
as of this
which I would say was the cost of the
podcast equipment we went to go with so
they've already made a return on their
investment on the podcast setup turn up
for the ROI and another cool thing
real-time activity at any given time in
48 hours there's about 80 200 people
watching their content so as of right
now maybe maybe there's like 2,000
people just on their stuff they're here
in the audience and they're chillin but
they got strategy 56,000 podcast streams
what this looks at this is 4,000 listens
a week but we they drop one podcast
episode a week and they're getting 4,000
listens average episodes about 15
minutes so you can imagine you got
44,000 people listening to you for an
hour every month pretty powerful and
then growing by 30 grand what does that
really mean that means they made a ton
of money uh that also means that 15
people are in their store at any given
time they're Shopify you can just hop on
and it just says that 15 people are in
there that's pretty crazy returning
customer rates about 70 and what that
speaks of is that people trust them and
it's because they've been able to give
away all this free value there's other
last brands there's other last companies
or the other last supplies but because
they're the ones telling you how to do
this stuff and never do they ever say
buy our stuff they're just like yo we're
gonna be doing these this wispy lash
look I'll be using these tweezers and
this glue let's get into it and then
people just alright I might as well just
buy it from them because because I trust
them tips for your first episode just
some tips for your first episode of your
podcasts
the strategy aspect of things so when
when we first started the podcast we
wanted to share Mike wanted to share the
story of how they came to where they are
and so he's like dude let's that let's
title his podcast the struggle is real
because that's the man the struggle is
real and I was like that's dope but
nobody's searching the struggle is real
right so I went on YouTube and I saw
that people were searching how to start
a lashe business with no money which
essentially was their story so that was
the title of their video that we of the
first their first podcast that they put
out and we did the research that's
simply research before you press record
right and so do the research your
podcasts could be reverse engineered so
don't just go out there and talk about
what you want to talk about see based
off of what you want to talk about go
ahead and search what you want to search
and and see what people are searching
and you can learn all this through VRA
we we learned that probably when you
start off you want to start with volume
so we started with eight podcasts for
the first two months so we dropped two
episodes every week for every month that
may sound like a lot for you guys but I
would actually disagree because we shot
those all in one day you can like power
tip to them power tip to me but at the
same time it's doable
just like hunker down and get her done I
don't know why I said that okay okay
and then another another thing that they
did up front and something you could do
is they they did a giveaway every
episode so it was about a month long
giveaway and when it when we they
announce the winner
the following episode they they started
a new giveaway and it increased share
ability it grew the email list for the
podcast but you can give away something
during the episode
another thing is this is all this may be
obvious maybe not be but post your
podcasts if you film them if you record
them post them on YouTube and post them
to podcasts you create the standard for
what your audience expects from you I
think I think this is powerful because I
wrote it I'm just kidding
well my chill bro I know it's fresh
though what I mean by that is because we
started off with long-form content
people met them with long-form content
and nobody will expect less from you and
so with every episode being about 15
minutes sometimes 20 sometimes 12
nobody's expecting less I would actually
say like on think media we're fighting
for attention because that it's
different kinds of content but we also
didn't start off this way so if you have
yet to start it's not a bad idea to
start with longer form content because
if people stumble on your stuff find
value they won't expect anything less
from you
thank you so what are some lessons we
learned so far number one that there's a
massive opportunity for your business
and brand to be on on have a podcast
secondly is that there's a people
waiting for you I think sometimes we
forget that we make it all about us like
I don't have this I look like this but
legit there's people waiting for content
that is coming from your perspective
coming from your in experiences and
things like that and so think about the
people I think that alleviates the the
pressure altogether in the sense that
there is a group of people that need
this stuff I need to get it into their
hands podcast can be monetized we
definitely learned that I would say
before I like tapped into the world of
like online marketing and networking and
stuff that I always thought podcasts
were like such a free thing and the way
we monetize this obviously is they have
the supply chain this can also be
monetized if they want to sell ad space
on their podcasts we actually though use
it they use it for their own promotion
so they self promote which which is what
you notice like they promote their
classes on there and they promote
speaking engagements they've also been
invited to speak at lash con this
October which is pretty crazy and why is
it so important for your business
who's raise your hand if you struggle
with consistency let's get everybody in
the room this is an easy way of getting
content done one shot angle talk
straight through if you have your like
points dialed in maybe or maybe you just
have the general idea what you want to
talk about but again if you're just
starting off just go for it it doesn't
have to be polished another reason is
because it gives you the ability to
repurpose the content what Shawn just
talked about like you can cut up five
pieces of micro content from your
podcast episode not having to ever sit
down again in front of the camera but
because it's pre its shot it's put
together
you can now dish out content on other
platforms and then it also builds trust
I think the coolest thing is they just
haven't had to sell anything they're
just like yo this is how you do stuff
this is what we've experienced this
is how we do our things here at our
company and it's that jab jab right hook
from garyvee mentality where if they
really want to ask they'll ask but they
actually don't need to but when they do
it's gonna be awesome because even be
like for sure we'll go to that live
event because we've been following you
guys for two years I can't wait to come
here and I think there's a handful of us
here right now because Shawn has hit you
a little bit with the jab jabs sorry
another good reason is you reach two
types of people simply making a video
podcast you reach two types people
people who listen to podcasts and people
who are on YouTube you uh hack watch
listen times what I like simply what I
talked about that just because it's
longer form you get to win on that end
and then here's just a legit stat that
there's over 500 million active users on
YouTube versus less than 1 million
podcasts so that's just a number to keep
in mind that shows that there's so much
opportunity in this space so conclusion
start podcasting now make some noise you
can start your podcast thanks for
checking out this episode we hope you
got a ton of value and if you haven't
already subscribe here to the think
marketing show wherever you're watching
or listening and hey it would mean the
world to us if you would rate and review
this show on Apple podcast as we grow
this movement of purpose-driven content
creators we encourage you to share it
with a friend and we'll see you in the
next episode